The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I'm asking for $100,000.
Ba-Bam!
Stop the madness.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
Whoa!
Oh!
You're turning down
almost a quarter-million dollars
from Mark Cuban?
Unbelievable.
Now I've seen everything.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
The offer Robert
is making you
is the kind of offer
they made in medieval times
When robber barons stole
people's companies from them.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
It's one of the most
interesting Inventions
America has ever seen.
It sold out in ten days.
There's companies out there
that are valuing this
at over $1.5 million.
But they're not
writing a check!
I have a service
that's going to revolutionize
the massage therapy industry.
You are a thief.
It's sink or swim.
Horrible idea!
I love it!
(Barbara) My offer's
off the table.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert
Who grew his homegrown
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
My name's Derek Pacque.
I'm 23 years old,
and I just graduated from
the Kelley School of Business
at Indiana University.
It has graduates such as
U.S. State senators,
C.E.O.S of fortune 500
companies,
and even mark cuban.
I got the idea for my business
when I was still at school.
Hey, guys, can you hand me
your jackets?
They're in the way.
I was hanging out
with some friends at a bar,
and it just came to me.
My college professor
liked my idea so much,
he actually decided
to become an investor.
This is the unit, right?
Not only is this business
a great idea,
but Derek is
a capable individual
that can really take
this business to great heights.
(Derek) Professor Hays
knows what it takes
to really get something
off the ground.
It's gonna cost
half a million dollars.
We don't want to raise
equity capital on that.
That's huge.
It's like giving...
Professor Hays and I make
a great team.
He brings a lot of experience,
and I bring a lot of energy.
(bells peal)
I have risked a lot
to turn this business
into a career.
I've put in all my savings,
I've taken money
from family and friends,
and turned down
many great job offers.
Getting a deal with the sharks
is exactly what I need
to turn my dream into a reality.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Derek Pacque,
and I'm a Hoo! Hoo! Hoo...
Hoosiers, baby.
Hoosier.
I'm the founder of CoatChex,
and I'm here today asking
for $200,000
for a 10% equity stake
in my company.
While attending
Indiana University,
I recognized a dilemma
that everyone faces
When they go out
in bad weather--
They either don't
wear a coat...
(Shivers) and Shiver,
or they could wear a soft,
warm, and cozy coat,
but then they have to
babysit it all night.
I wish I'd put
a leash on mine
because one night,
it was stolen
while throwing down my favorite
moves on the dance floor.
I was so mad
that I went up to a manager
and I asked them why
they didn't have a coat check.
They told me it was
way too much of a hassle.
So I asked them, "can I
open one up myself?"
before I knew it,
I had two coat checks
set up in my college town.
During this time,
I came to realize
why no one
provides coat checks.
This is the security.
It's just not organized
or effective.
May I present to you
our ticketless
coat check system?
With our innovative technology,
we match a person's face
to their belonging.
You simply hand over
your coat
and then type your name
into the system,
and a picture is taken
automatically.
All you do from there,
you just pay.
It's that easy.
There's no more dealing
with tickets.
She can now see a picture
of the person and their coat
to make sure she's giving it
back to the right person.
It is time
to turn an inconvenience
into an opportunity.
So how 'bout one of you
writes me a check?
And I'll check you
into coatchex.
Do you have any sales?
No, I've not made--
the technology,
we just started.
Derek, what is the business?
Is the business the service
or are you trying
to sell the technology?
We're franchising.
We have a system now
and we have equipment
so that anyone can sort of
do what I did.
So you want to sell
the computer, the design...
Yes.
Everything.
I buy the franchise...
exactly.
That's the business model?
Okay. So, Derek,
what is the plan
to sell $100,000
of these units?
We're starting to get agreements
with area developers right now.
For example, in Chicago,
someone says to me, "Hey--
I need 50 franchises opened.
"I'm willing
to put down $150,000
"to start off in equipment
to get this out there
in Chicago."
So wait, wait,
let me get this straight--
You have not sold
any of these yet?
Nope. We just--
So you haven't had
a chance to test it, right?
Yeah.
And you're going out
and you're selling franchises
to area developers...
who are--
Who are then gonna, in turn,
go and sell them to franchisees?
Exactly.
Horrible!
Horrible idea!
Let me ask you something.
How do you really feel
about it?
Horrible!
Because you haven't tested it.
Anybody who's done anything
in technology knows
that the only certainty
is that it's gonna screw up.
Derek, why don't you go
to the busiest steakhouse
near where you live,
and say to the person there
that owns it,
"Let me install this
for free.
"you've got 500 coats
coming in here every night.
Let me watch it work
for 90 days."
Why wouldn't you do that?
I want to. It's just too warm
right now in Indianapolis.
(sharks laugh)
I love it!
So it's seasonal.
How many of those coats
did you steal yourself?
You're asking for 10%
for $200,000, right?
Yes, I know this.
So for $2 million
that you're valuating
your company at,
you are a thief.
Let me tell you why
I'm valuating it at $2 million.
I'm so fascinated.
I would love to hear why.
We have a patent on
our ticketless bailment system.
Bailment?
Bailment--It's whenever you hand
over a belonging to someone,
and they keep it
for a certain period of time.
Give me another example.
Valet, dry cleaning,
rental services,
um, any kind of
baggage holding services.
Oh.
You have a patent
on all of that?
Yes.
That's--That's interesting. But--
You're not investing
in just coat checks.
We want to get this
into all the different
bailment situations.
You're just in
the development stage.
Exactly.
What's the whole capital cost
to put all this together?
We were gonna sell it
for $1,500.
Walk us through the money.
How much do you charge
to check a coat?
Anywhere from $2 to $5,
depending on the scale
of the event.
How do you pay the people
that own the venue?
Revenue split. We gain
15% of revenue.
15? 1-5?
15. 1-5.
Are there any other competitors
out there like this?
Nothing like this at all.
I know a little bit
about this space.
And unfortunately,
I think you're incorrect.
There are similar products.
I don't think you're educated
enough in this space,
but I think
you have a lot of drive.
I'm out.
You don't have a--a plan
for distribution and sales,
which is the greatest challenge.
You can only sell this
six months of the year.
It's a seasonal sale.
Summer comes along,
nobody cares.
I hate seasonal businesses.
And for that reason, Derek,
I'm out.
It struck me like it takes
entirely too long
to check in a coat.
What we're gonna do is,
essentially,
it's gonna be an iphone app,
you just come up,
scan your Q.R. Code.
(Barbara) I think it's easier
to get a ticket and run.
I'm out.
So, Derek, let's take stock
of where we're at right now.
Okay. Yeah, yeah.
You've got three
sharks out.
Mm-hmm.
On either end are two
that are still in.
Mm-hmm.
I'd ignore
the guys in the middle.
Start working on trying to get
some money out of these people.
Okay. Well, I'd like
to say one thing--
I'm just out of college.
This is why I'm here.
I'm trying to figure out
the best ways to scale this.
One of my partners
is my professor
who did venture capital
and entrepreneurial finance.
You know--
Derek, I like the idea.
You can go to universities
and other venues,
you franchise it
down the road...
Mm-hmm.
And that becomes part of
the proprietary advantage,
is you lock those venues down.
So you do
a multiyear contract
with dance halls, sports bars,
and places like that.
Museums, malls.
And then you hire a couple guys
to try to pitch it
to dry cleaners
or places like that.
But it's worth
$2 million, Robert.
I--I can't get
to the $2 million.
Help me out there.
I'm willing to negotiate.
(laughs)
Oh, you think?
You gotta start high.
I mean, come on.
Let's be real here.
And at the same--You know,
I'll take more money.
Let's talk--
Let's talk numbers.
(sharks laugh)
You will take more money?
I wanna be clear on that.
Robert, I don't know
a guy in the hood,
I know a guy
in Beverly Hills
that'll go around hanging
your coats for $2 million.
(laughter)
Mark, where are you at
with this?
Look, I like it, but I need
to know more about you.
Okay.
Okay, so you walk
in the door,
and I'm telling you,
your business plan is horrible.
(Robert)
Yeah. Yeah, it's pretty bad.
What plan?
What do you mean, "what plan"?
here's the plan--
I wanna get $2 million
and leave.
There's gonna be
hard decisions to make.
Are you the type of person
that you'll do the right thing
and you'll make
the hard decisions?
That's what I want
to know.
I don't--
Yes, but I'm all open
to listening to people
who have been there before.
So, Derek, I-I love this.
I just...
make me another offer
Under $2 million.
I can't get
to the $2 million.
Um...
uh...
I asked for $200,000
because it's-It's a start.
It's gonna get me
to commercialization.
He--He asked you
a very, very simple question.
♪♪♪
Make me another offer
under $2 million.
I can't get
to the $2 million.
Um, I asked for $200,000
because it's--It's a start.
It's gonna get me
to commercialization.
He--He asked you
a very, very simple question.
Okay. Um...
for $200,000...
Let's start talking...
$1.5 mil valuation?
Does that work?
What would that be?
Uh, 15%?
I'll start talking
$1.5 mil.
So he went from 10%
to 15%. His company is now
$1.5 million, Robert.
Zero sales.
I'm out.
And then there was just
one left.
Let's take a step back.
Makes perfect sense
in my mind,
particularly since
you haven't tested it,
or really have
a track record yet,
to build "X" number
of these things
and take them where we can
create a track record.
Because once you've created
a track record
in any business,
your leverage and your value
goes like this.
I've been doing that
my entire adult life.
But you need the help.
I do.
And so this isn't a partnership
that's just about cash.
Your issue is knowledge
and experience.
Yes.
So I'm gonna make you
an offer,
and you can say "Yes" or "No"
very quickly,
because I don't mess around.
The offer is $200,000
for 33%.
Because I have--
Are you crazy?
Relax.
This is a great offer.
Love the offer.
You're ruining the tank
by Giving this kind
of money away.
Can I talk to my business
partner about this?
Go ahead and call
your business partner.
I can call him
real quick?
Real quick.
Thank you so much.
Uh-huh.
Well, Mark, you just
gave him a $600,000 valuation.
Honestly, if it does
what it says it does,
I could flip it
in silicon valley
in about 15 seconds.
Jerry. So we got
an offer from mark--
$200,000 for 33%.
Honestly, he threw out
a great, um, pitch on his part
for why he's gonna
help us get out there.
You know, we haven't
proven anything.
We're here really early.
Everyone else is going crazy
that he's giving this offer.
(Hays) I think you're giving
away a lot of equity
this early in the game.
I would pass. I wouldn't--
I wouldn't do it.
And what we haven't
discussed yet
is that you take it
to New York...
your value is worth 90%.
You take it to new York
and big cities
where they charge $10,
$15, $20 for coat check?
Mark, you're valuing
the company at $600,000.
You're spoiling
the "Shark Tank" kids.
Don't do this.
Listen, Mark,
I'm from Pittsburgh,
you're from Pittsburgh.
Don't be a foolish man.
I would love
to work with you.
Let me--Let me finish.
Oh, oh, oh!
You guys are right.
I came here too early.
I wanted to prove
to you guys
that this is a business
that I could really
turn into
a $2 million company.
What are you saying?
You have an offer. Are you
taking it or not?
I would--
don't be a hoosier bozo.
For right now, that is
the valuation of the company.
I think I should continue
to develop it a little bit more.
Whoa!
Oh, no!
To prove it to you.
I need to prove it to you.
You're turning down
almost a quarter-million dollars
from Mark Cuban?
Unbelievable!
There's companies out there
that are valuing this
at over $1.5 million.
I--Listen--
But they're not writing
a check!
They're not giving you
any money!
Give him an answer!
Yes or no?
Slow down and think about it
one more time.
Derek, everybody checked out
on your valuation.
$2 million, $1.5 million.
You basically have
an experiment--
No disrespect to you.
I have other people
involved, and...
(Barbara)
Who are telling you "No."
(Daymond) counter.
They are telling me "No."
Counter.
Uh...
do you know
how few people get
what you have right now
in your hand,
in "Shark Tank"?
practically nobody!
I know.
Let him answer.
I get it.
Well, he has nothing
right now.
I--
Let him answer.
$200,000 for 20%.
No.
Wow. I admire the guts.
Thanks, guys, for your time.
Unbelievable.
Now I've seen everything.
I'm in dead shock
that I just turned down
a deal from Mark Cuban.
It's--I-I still to this moment
don't know...
just don't know what happened.
♪♪♪
Last season, Rick Hopper made
a $150,000 deal with Lori
for 65% of his company,
Readerest.
I'll make you a millionaire.
Let's rock, Lori.
We're gonna rock.
Whoo-Hoo!
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Ever since going
on "Shark Tank,"
things couldn't be better.
When I was making these
by hand in my garage,
I could only make
150 a day.
Right now, in my
6,000-square foot facility,
we're making 14,000 a day.
Before "Shark Tank,"
my entire life Sales
was only $65,000.
Since I made a deal with Lori,
we've done $3 million in sales
in 10 short months.
2 1/2 weeks? No problem.
We can deliver.
We've recently gotten
into Walmart and Walgreens.
We're in the process
of shipping right now.
Our projection is
$30 to $50 million dollars
in the next few years.
We just got an order
for 10,000 more, you guys!
(cheering)
Making a deal with Lori was
the best thing I ever did.
She said She was gonna
make me a millionaire,
and here we are.
(Lori) Hi, guys!
I didn't know what to expect
when I went on "Shark Tank."
The last thing
I would imagine
is I'd be on Martha's Vineyard
with Lori
Celebrating mad success.
(Lori) It is less than a year
since we started
this venture together.
Let's open a bottle
of Champagne to celebrate.
Rick, he had a dream.
For me, there's nothing
more impactful
than changing somebody's life.
(pops)
(cheering)
people I've talked to
over the last several months,
they hope that
"Shark Tank" is legit...
(clinks)
to Readerest.
They hope that my relationship
with Lori is great.
They hope that I'm making
a ton of money.
And it's true.
It just proves
that dreams really come true.
♪♪♪
My name Jay Kriner,
and I am an unexploded ordnance
technician.
I dispose of bombs.
There are millions
of unexploded devices
all around the world...
(beeps)
From a tiny bullet
to a major missile
that was rocket propelled.
There's very little room
for error.
If something did happen,
there could be a "ba-boom,"
and there's no more Jay.
Bombs pay the bills right now,
But family comes first.
My wife Jenna and I
are having our first kid,
so it's extremely important
that I stay out of harm's way.
With my product, I know that
I can create a safer future
for me and my family.
I've put tons of years
of thought into this.
Now it's time to take it
to the next level.
And with the sharks' help,
I know this business will...
ba-bam!
Hello. My name is Jay Kriner,
and my product and business
is the Bev Buckle.
I am seeking $50,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my business.
The Bev Buckle is one of
the most interesting Inventions
America has ever seen.
Picture this--You're at
a sporting event,
a concert,
fishing at the river,
and you feel the need
to free up your hands
of your beverage...
Ba-bam!
(Robert) Oh, my god.
(sharks laugh)
Oh-Ho-Ho, man!
Oh, that is a great idea.
It's the only buckle
on the market
that can fold out
to hold your beverage.
Did Christmas come early?
Yes, it did.
(laughter)
Everyone knows someone
Who would want one.
I can design the faceplate
to have any brand,
any logo, and any color.
Licensing, branding.
So keep
that cold beverage close,
and those hands free,
because it's the Bev Buckle.
Ba-Bam!
Ba-Bam, baby!
How did you come up
with this idea?
I was in college,
and I'm out
with my friends a lot,
and we went to bars,
having some good times,
and I-I just--out of habit,
I kept doing this.
And I thought to myself,
man, if I could just
hold my beer hands-free,
I could, uh, maybe show off
my poor dance moves, or...
(laughs)
Can I see one of
those buckles? Do you mind?
Absolutely.
Doesn't come with the belt?
Thank you, sir.
It's heavy. Whoo.
Is it a magnet
that's holding it closed?
It is.
Do you have any sales now?
I have actually
gone across America
and personally sold,
at festivals and other events,
over 4,000 units.
Over what period of time?
Over four years.
What does that translate to
in sales?
We're at $340,000.
Do you have a patent?
Yes.
What's your cost
to make these?
It's, uh, $10.
And I sell it for $35,
up to $110,
depending on
what's on the face.
Let's ask Mr. China here.
It's a good price?
Pretty good price, Yeah.
What's your
full-time job, Jay?
I just got out of school
to be an unexploded ordnance
technician.
What does that mean?
Identification
and remediation
on unexploded
military ordnance.
So it's like "The Hurt Locker"?
you're looking
for guys with bombs?
Absolutely.
Do you want to do that?
That is my plan "B."
I need something that I can
provide for my family.
I got my first kid
on the way,
so I have to have something
to fall back on.
The only problem
with your job,
if you make
a mistake one day,
you'll be in five pieces.
This is true.
There are no mistakes.
So, Jay,
what's the game plan?
You get the $50,000.
Yeah?
What happens tomorrow?
I'll actually let you choose
Between option number 1
and option number 2.
(sharks laugh)
I love this guy!
Which one of you
want to see
which is in what?
Number 1!
I have a list for you
of some people
that want it
in every store they own.
So here you've got
Urban Outfitters,
Cowboy Harley Davidson,
Boston Beer Company,
Seaside Marketing.
And number 2 is a list
of every major raceway
that wants the buckle
sold trackside.
Daytona, Talladega,
Darlington, Michigan,
Watkins Glen,
Nascar and other
pro events.
Any of those people
written you a check?
No, because
I have an issue.
I came into a problem
with my manufacturer.
My recent Order
was 26% defective.
Whoa.
Yes.
Bad news, Jay.
Can I see that, please?
Why wouldn't you have taken
a purchase order
from anybody on this list?
I don't have working capital
to supply that.
If I got a check in advance,
I could seal the deal.
Are you gonna work
full-time on this?
If I'm able to, absolutely.
What does that mean?
You need a salary?
Something's gotta
pay the bills.
And the bombs,
I'd rather not do.
How much money would you need
to make it a full-time job?
Past mortgage and bills...
Let's say it's, uh,
$2,000, $3,000.
A month?
A month.
Okay.
So this is what
the list is worth...
when I started,
everybody said they wanted it,
but nobody wrote a check.
You're asking to value a company
at half a million dollars,
and then also to teach you.
I won't have the time
to help you. I'm out.
Jay, how much do you have
in inventory right now?
62 units.
Jay, look, the math
is not adding up for me.
You've had these same
exact challenges for four years,
and nothing has changed.
I'm not saying
you're not working hard.
Maybe it's just that
you're not working smart.
I'm out.
Mark is right.
You're running faster every day
and you're standing still.
You're not getting anywhere.
I don't have
a problem with that.
That was me.
I didn't know what to do.
I learned from others.
It's gonna suck up
a lot of my time,
but here's what I'll do--
I'll give you the $50,000
for 75%.
You just need some guidance,
my friend.
I think you're on
the right track.
Okay, the offer
Robert is making you
is the kind of offer
they made in medieval times,
when robber barons
roamed the land
and stole people's
companies from them.
75% gone.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $50,000,
and I don't want
any equity in it, okay?
I'd like to get
a royalty on the top
of every one sold.
I want 12%, and I'll give you
your $50,000.
Frankly, I'd rather do this
than see you
blown up with mines.
I would rather
be doing that, too.
How much do you want this?
Really bad.
This buckle can continue
to leech along
and--And snail
its way through,
or it can just boom.
Let's go
to sporting goods stores,
and say it's another accessory
while you fish.
It has other avenues,
so let's open those up.
You know, Jay, I'm jumping in,
and I'll do it for 51%
to knock him
out of the box,
'cause he's overeating
and he's greedy.
Last thing I am is greedy.
But you cannot take a salary
from that $50,000,
simply 'cause the math
doesn't work.
Well, what's he gonna live on?
I think that's insane,
that you would give up 75%.
I do, too.
It's crazy.
What for?
That's just crazy.
I wouldn't even listen
to that noise.
What, you're saying
your offer is better, O'Leary?
The problem with
that offer is,
when you're growing a business,
the last thing you want to do
is send 12% of the cash flow
out the business.
You're here
because you need cash.
Jay, I want you
to take a coffee cup
and put it right there
on your belt buckle,
'cause coffee is
for closers.
I want you to close on
one of those guys right now.
Make a decision.
What are you gonna do?
Life is full of choices.
You gotta pick one,
my friend.
I think the best person
to come into business with...
to be honest with you,
I think Barbara.
You're a smart guy.
You made a mistake,
my friend.
Good decision.
Thank you very much.
Best decision.
Thank you.
You made a mistake.
You gave up control
of your company.
Thank you, all.
(singsongy) He's gonna be rich.
Thank you, Jay.
Ba-Bam!
♪♪♪
Next up is Todd Miller,
who feels he has reinvigorated
the ancient art of massage.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Todd Miller.
I'm a licensed massage therapist
and founder of
the bodywalking institute.
I am here today
asking for $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
I have a product,
I have a service,
that's going to revolutionize
the massage therapy industry.
Who loves a good massage?
Barbara. Mark.
A truly great
therapeutic massage
is all about applying as much
isolated pressure as possible.
Wouldn't it be smarter
to use our feet?
That's why I have
created bodywalking.
By standing on you,
I am able to limit
blood flow temporarily.
When I come off
that area,
the blood shoots back in there
like a tsunami.
It feels incredible.
I'm able to apply
more pounds per square inch,
which causes the body
to just let go.
I invite one of you to come over
here and experience bodywalking.
Barbara, please come.
I have so much pain
sitting next to this character
for three years.
If you just turn your head
to one side or the other,
whatever's comfortable.
Todd, please,
step on her head.
(laughs)
Mr. Wonderful's stress
is leaving your body.
Are you using
full force, Todd?
What I'm doing is applying
8 to 15 seconds of compression.
It's all about
listening to Barbara's body.
Todd, how much do you weigh?
I weigh 190, sir.
So you're putting 190 pounds
on her leg.
Barb, how does that feel?
I mean,
he is not a small guy.
Barb?
(Robert laughs)
Rigor mortis is
starting to set in.
(Robert laughs)
Can you please
lift Barbara up?
How are you doing
down there?
(mark, ghoulish voice)
she's alive! She's alive!
My god, that was great.
I'm in contact with
the biggest massage therapy
clinic provider in the U.S.
710 outlets,
one certified bodywalker,
and they're $1,500 a head.
That's what you charge
to get certified? $1,500?
Yes, sir.
Todd, hang on.
People walk
on other people's back
for a massage for a long time.
(Barbara) It's not new,
obviously.
Absolutely not.
They've been doing it in Asia
for thousands of years.
Okay, so--
But it's a new angle
for Americans.
Is that what you're saying?
Yes.
How many certified bodywalkers
do you have?
30.
How long did it take you
to enlist those 30?
I've been doing--certifying
bodywalking since 2005.
So you're saying you basically,
uh, did 30 people...
in seven years.
In seven years?
Yes.
Four people a year?
It's not sounding great, Todd.
I understand, Robert.
That's why I'm here.
The bottom line is, it works.
As a 20-time ironman
triathlete,
I would not be here
unless it was for bodywalking.
But, Todd, I can't send you
all over America doing massages.
You are correct, sir.
That's why if we have
ten classes a month--
Ten. Just ten--
and we have 20 people
in those classes,
that's revenue of $300,000.
When was the last time
you ran a triathlon?
Almost nine months ago.
And how much training
do you need to do
before you go into
a triathlon?
You're training every day.
Which is your passion?
Mark, I've been thinking
about that question
all freakin' season,
'cause I love your questions.
(laughs)
My passion is
to generate your return
on this investment
quicker than anybody's
ever done.
You haven't given me
an answer, Todd.
Everybody likes to talk about
following their passions,
when in reality, they should be
following their efforts.
Just the time you put
into the triathlon
is time that could be spent
selling,
creating new certifications.
It tells me that my money
and your money
is not your primary focus.
Mark, that's not fair.
It is fair,
because you know what?
No, it's not fair.
It is fair.
That's crap.
No, it's crap, mark.
(Robert speaks indistinctly)
Mark, that's crap.
I understand.
You think triathlon is
this gargantuous thing that
you have to do all the time.
It's what keeps me happy.
You make choices.
(Robert) No way, man.
This guy's not a quitter,
though, mark.
When I had my first company,
I went seven years
without a vacation.
Mark, you--
But my girlfriends--
When my girlfriend says,
"It's me or your company,"
my answer was,
"What was your name again?"
(Robert) Come on, mark.
(speaks indistinctly)
Yeah, I had my first business,
I went seven years without food.
But it doesn't matter.
But your choices
to distribute your effort
among multiple things...
I hear ya,
but if I'm not healthy,
I'm gonna get overweight.
I'm gonna be a problem
to this country.
I'm not interested
in investing in balance.
I'm interested in investing
in somebody whose sole focus
is to be a success
at their business.
And I don't see that in you,
so I'm out.
I have to tell you something.
I am the queen of massages,
and I really,
with all due respect,
do not find this unique
in any way.
I'm out.
I don't see anything
proprietary.
I mean, look--
It goes back to the numbers,
the potential of--
Potential is not sales, Todd.
10% of that market is
40,000 therapists.
Potential is not sales.
I'm out.
I don't think
you've done a good job
of telling us what the plan is
here today.
You haven't proven the model
to sell a product.
So for that reason,
I gotta walk. I'm out.
I'm a very simple man.
I just want to make money.
I'll listen to anybody
until I get to the point
where I realize,
I can't make any money,
and that's where I'm at now
with you.
So for that reason--
Mr. Wonderful, may I...
therapists run up to me
and thank me.
World-Class athletes--
It's all about--
Todd, you're a dead man walking
to me. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you very much.
(Mark) Good luck, Todd.
All the best.
Thank you very much.
I guarantee
once America experiences
bodywalking,
they will run to
their massage therapist
and yell, "become
a certified bodywalker."
♪♪♪
Next up is Maria Curcio
and Veronica Perlongo,
who believe they have
a solution
to a nationwide epidemic.
Hi. My name is
Veronica Perlongo,
and this is my partner
of 15 years Maria Curcio.
Our product is BuggyBeds,
and we are seeking
a $125,000 investment
for 7% equity
in our company.
Bedbugs are crawling everywhere.
These simple little
fabric hitchhikers
have been causing panic
and chaos across the world.
Bedbug infestations Have
increased over 500%
in the last few years alone,
causing a global epidemic.
Stop the madness!
A simple twin bed like this
can have thousands to hundreds
of thousands of bedbugs
feeding on you,
causing you red, swollen,
itchy lumps.
And one female
can lay up to 500 eggs.
Wow.
You could have bedbugs in
your home and not even know it.
And that's why we created...
BuggyBeds!
(chuckles)
BuggyBeds is a bedbug glue trap
that is
an early detection system.
It's designed to attract,
trap bedbugs dead.
Simply slide and hide buggybed
between your box spring mattress
or under your couch cushions.
And BuggyBeds provide
peace of mind for everyone.
(both) Sleep tight
and don't let the bedbugs bite.
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
Well, let's see
who's gonna bite.
Can we have a look
at the product?
Absolutely.
Sure.
Veronica's gonna hand you out
our travel pack.
You take it with you
to hotel rooms.
(Mark) How long have you guys
been doing this?
We launched the product
about six months ago.
Why we're here is,
we have weaknesses
for big box distribution
and the retail stores.
Oh, so you want help in getting
retail distribution?
Correct.
Does this eradicate
all of the bedbugs?
This has been designed,
actually,
as an early detection system.
Is your vision that I would
go to a hotel
with one of these...
correct.
Put it under my bed, and say,
"Whoa!"
Correct.
"I gotta change rooms.
There's bugs in here"?
we've actually
even had that happen.
Whoa.
Everyone keeps asking
the same question--
"Why are we so infested?"
Because there is no really good
early detection system.
Early detection.
Is it tested and proven
or is this your claim?
Yes, it's--We've tested it.
We worked with a couple
entomologists, dermatologists,
as well as myself.
Came up with a formula.
We just had a housing authority,
for instance.
We sent them a case
of 144 traps,
at their request for a sample,
three months ago.
They just placed an order
last week for 22,000 traps
because of
the successful results.
(Robert) Wow. It's not toxic
in any way? I mean...
No, it's nontoxic
and pesticide-Free.
BuggyBeds is patented
as a design in 34 countries.
The trademark of the name
BuggyBeds and the logo itself
is in 42 countries.
The utility is pending
in 50 countries.
(Kevin) Who is actually doing
the manufacturing for you?
We're actually taking it
in-house now 100%.
It's very cost effective
and easy.
What is the suggested
retail price of each of those?
The 2-packs are, uh,
$6.99 to $8.99.
And what is your cost
of making it?
$1.35.
What are your sales right now?
Uh, currently,
our sales are $150,000.
We started with
Home Depot's web site,
and they just picked us up
for 60 of their stores
that we just shipped out
this week.
Whoa! You never said that
before.
With this product?
Correct.
We also just got
a purchase order from
75 Burlington Coat Factories
as well.
Can I say one other thing?
On the $150,000 in sales,
we have $100,000 in profit.
Nice.
For six months
since you've introduced it?
Correct.
$150,000 for 6 months.
You're valuing the company--
You're asking for $125,000
for 7%, correct?
Correct.
You're saying the company's
valued around $1.75 million.
Why are you valuing the company
at that?
That's a great question.
Before we launched,
I was offered $5 million
for the trademarks
and the patent from a company.
(sharks) Whoa!
Wait a minute.
And you turned that down?
Yes.
What?!
Shame on you!
Are you... uh...
I'm Mrs. Wonderful of business.
I know what we have here.
I know the value.
We did a test market
in 29 stores of shoprite.
They contacted us.
The entire corporation sold out
in 10 days in 29 stores.
We just had a Walmart
local manager look at it.
The first thing said is,
"Wow! This is eye candy.
You can have it--have it
in front of the register."
I like her. (laughs)
Wow. You two bedbugs are
the real deal.
I-I think we know you guys are
I'm itching to do this deal.
(all laugh)
Okay. Ladies, ladies,
I want you to step outside
for me, okay?
Because I want us to have
a little shark discussion, okay?
Uh-Oh.
Okay, boys and girl,
we all want part of this deal.
So what do you want
to go up to?
I'd like to see
what they're offering.
I think they're very interested
and I think they're gonna--
Depends on what value they're
gonna bring to the table.
Yeah.
I mean, it depends--
You know, I'm not gonna give up
something what we have.
We have tremendous value.
Right.
I want to avoid a shark fight.
I want a piece of the deal.
I know everybody else
are thinking the same thing.
I want collusion.
She turned down $5 million.
Yeah, she turned down
$5 million.
Do you really wanna go in
about the dollars
or getting all five of us?
We have to give her something
of tremendous value.
All five of us for 25%?
Yeah, all five of us are
tremendous value.
Well, I'd rather have
a bigger chunk for myself,
to be honest with you.
I'm always, uh, wary
when Kevin does all the talking
and Mark doesn't say a word.
I'm just listening.
Are you in on this?
I have nothing to say.
♪♪♪
(Kevin) Lets buy a big piece
of this business.
Is everybody interested?
We have to give her something
of tremendous value.
All five of us for 25%?
Yeah, all five of us are
tremendous value.
Well, I'd rather have
a bigger chunk for myself,
to be honest with you.
Mark, are you in on this?
I'll be brutally honest.
I'm gonna let you guys talk.
I'm gonna listen and see what
they say and decide from there.
Well, it's not gonna
go anywhere
unless somebody starts
with an offer.
Okay, well, I'll start
with an offer,
and I'll say anybody who wants
to join me is welcome in.
Ladies!
So what would really
get me excited
about working
with both of you ladies
is 25% of the company,
and I'm willing to give you
$250,000 for it.
But I also respect
my fellow sharks,
and I don't want
to compete with them,
so I will invite any one of them
into that deal.
They may elect to join me
or they may not.
We'll see what happens now.
Any other offers from anyone?
I'm willing to come in
on Kevin's deal.
Okay.
(mouths word)
I'm curious to see
what you think
of Kevin and Daymond's offer.
Um, the equity is
a little higher
than what we wanted
to give up.
But if another shark
comes in on that,
'cause it's strategic,
it's the same equity.
I wanna work
on the Walmart deal.
I've lived through rolling out
products in Walmart.
It's very hard.
I wanna help you.
7-Eleven has 40,000 stores
globally,
so I can help you with that.
I wanna speak for the value
we bring beyond just the cash.
I mean, there's a lot of value
in having us as partners.
We have to get paid for that,
too.
Everybody has to wet their beak.
Mark, are you in on this?
I have nothing to say.
Can we just discuss
what you would be bringing
as far as other help
you can give us?
For starters, they would bring
their huge egos with them.
It...
Ladies, I'm gonna give you
an offer now.
You have to accept it now.
All right? I'm not gonna wait.
I don't have time
for the little boy games.
So I'm gonna give you $150,000
for 15% of the business.
But I'm gonna tell you what
I'm gonna bring to the table.
I had to learn how to break into
the big box stores.
I didn't know a darn thing
about it three years ago.
I know it inside and out.
But you know what else? You
girls are cut of the same cloth.
We don't need these boys
to help us find our success.
They weren't there
when we were struggling.
Girl power!
They're not gonna be there
at the end.
What is this?
And that's the truth. All right?
Barbara, let's just get to your
blood-sucking offer, please.
Reiterate it again.
All right.
And you wanna know what else?
(Kevin) is there an offer
at the end of this?
I already gave the offer.
Make sure the phone bill's
in there,
because as long-winded
as she is,
you will be on the phone
forever.
(Maria and Veronica laugh)
you realize
they're both giving you
basically the same value
of the company.
Correct.
Ladies, do you accept the offer
or not?
Keep in mind, Maria, you've got
the offer from Daymond and Kevin
for $250,000 for 25%,
and Mark and I haven't made
any offer yet.
Okay, So, Barbara,
are you in or out?
My offer's off the table.
I'm out.
Too bad.
I love your business.
You guys have everything
under control, basically.
The issue really is,
can you run fast enough
to keep up with everything?
Mm-hmm.
You have no idea.
I think the best deal is
for the four of us--
and actually, if Barbara wants
to come back in--
the five of us on the--
You're being a gentleman.
No, I'll leave the boys club
up to the boys.
The only reason I would, uh,
make my offer
is to screw over Mark Cuban.
Ha!
But I think each of us can
add something, as Mark said.
I'm in on the deal with Mark,
Daymond, and Kevin.
$250,000 for 25%.
(Kevin) Come on, Barbara.
Barbara, you should come in.
I'm gonna tell you something.
I don't even like these guys,
But just to make
your life pleasant,
I'm gonna jump back in the deal.
Before she changes her mind,
you have all five sharks,
quarter of a million dollars
for 25% of the company.
Never happens ever.
Yes or no?
Okay, can we take on minute to--
No.
(Kevin and Barbara)
Don't even think about it.
I have one request.
Will you teach me
the Cha-Cha-Cha?
(laughs) It's a deal.
(laughs)
It's a deal.
Wow!
(Daymond) That is history.
(Kevin) Wow!
Thank you very much.
Congratulations to you, guys.
You guys are gonna do great.
Now go back and sprinkle bedbugs
in every hotel
and restaurant you can.
(laughs)
Yes!
We did it, baby!
All five of them. Whoo-Hoo!
Barbara, your greed almost
killed that deal for all of us.
Yeah, you're a savage.
Bedbugs--My best friends.
They're your relatives.
Well, it's a great business.
Having all five sharks get in
the deal together
was amazing
for it to ever happen.
That's tremendous for us.